[Music]
no your eyes are not deceiving you
that is ashley olsen in the wild the
bizarre sighting was captured by her
longtime boyfriend louis eisner
who posted a few pics on instagram
including a
very rare photo of ashley herself the 35
year old fashion mogul seems to be in
her natural element
taking a hike with a drink in one hand
and a large machete in the other
you never know what's going to happen
while we don't know what exactly is
going on
we can see that she's wearing a white
sweatshirt linen pants
a button-up shirt tied around her waist
and a pair of black yeezy sneakers
ashley is also rocking a baseball cap
and oversized
sunglasses there's a lot going on with
this look but
we gotta say the machete kind of
completes it to be honest
in florida fans were obviously
captivated by the exquisite pick
and shared their thoughts on twitter one
tweet read
this rare pic of ashley olsen just
radiates my energy and i freaking love
it
another fan wrote ashley olsen got her
machete and wandered off into the woods
to free brittany
while someone else shared ashley olsen
wearing yeezys
drinking beer carrying a machete in the
middle of the forest is my
summer mood board she's got a machete
and a cocktail it seems normal we're not
sure
even ashley's former full house co-star
john stamos is just
as confused as the rest of us i haven't
talked to him in a while
but maybe is it getting ready for
halloween or something i don't know
i don't know anyway in the very next
photo her boyfriend
is seen standing on a log over a body of
water ashley and the 32 year old painter
were first spotted together in october
2017.
they sparked engagement rumors when the
actress was seen wearing a ring on that
finger in july 2019.
of course we know that ashley and her
twin sister mary kay olson are
notoriously private
the child icons recently gave an
interview to id magazine where they
explained their lifestyle
and how it inspires their fashion label
the row mary kate said quote we were
raised to be discreet people
while ashley added that's just our
aesthetic our design
preference we do everything together and
while the famous twin
is discreet we're here for this ashley
olsen energy